l'examen du rapport d'information de nos
deux collègues Laurent marquant jelly et
Estelle
je dis Marc Angélil à parisienne
si vous voulez oui et celle Youssoupha
sont les enjeux migratoires aux
frontières sud de l'Union européenne et
en océan Indien alors je vais pas
déflorer évidemment le travail et les
conclusions ne rapporteurs je me
borderai à titre liminaire à remarquer
que l'actualité illustre le caractère
essentiel de cette question le 24 avril
dernier comme vous le savez le
gouvernement a lancé une des plus vastes
opérations de lutte contre les
migrations clandestine à Mayotte
intitulé wambushu ce qui signifie
reprise en Mahoré elle mobilise quelques
1800 policiers et gendarmes et vise à
expulser les étrangers en situation
irrégulière à détruire les bidons villes
et à lutter contre la criminalité dans
ce département
confronté à l'une dépression migratoire
les plus élevées de notre pays notamment
en provenance des Comores il est évident
qu'une opération de cet ordre ne pouvait
être que assez controversé et la
controverse a été menée avec force de
part et d'autre et notamment par notre
collègue Estelle qui s'est signalé par
une très grande puniacité et un très
grand degré de conviction dans le même
temps ainsi que l'indiqué le directeur
exécutif de l'Agence Européenne Frontex
et Jour Dernier le nombre d'entrées
irrégulières dans l'Union européenne par
la Méditerranée centrale a augmenté de
près de 300% sur le premier quadrimé sur
2023 par rapport à 2022 300% c'est
effectivement un chiffre appréciable les
flux en provenance de Tunisie notamment
connaissent une croissance exponentielle
vous allez nous parler je vous laisse
donc sans tarder la parole puis nous
échangerons sur le contenu du rapport
présenté selon les formes que nous avons
que nous pratiquons désormais et qui
sont celles du ping-pong après la
Commission se prononcera sur la
publication de votre rapport alors le
celui ou celle qui commence c'est
c'est Monsieur Marc Angel
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues permettez-moi dans un premier
temps de remercier ma collègue et sel
Youssoupha pour le travail que nous
avons mené dans une bonne ambiance
malgré un gravité des enjeux qui nous
ont amenés à nous réunir et à
auditionner un certain nombre de
personnes et à faire des déplacements et
je vous remercie également monsieur
Legrain notre administrateur qui est a
été précieux comme tous les
administrateurs de cette maison à la
hauteur des enjeux et d'une aide
particulièrement forte
mais chers collègues il y a 8 ans éclaté
ce que l'on a appelé la crise des
réfugiés de 2015
en l'espace d'appel un an afflué dans
l'Union européenne plus d'un million de
migrants essentiellement syrien et
afghan mais aussi irakien ou encore
pakistanais la Grèce avec ces myriadeal
et sa frontière terrestre avec la
Turquie se trouvait en première ligne
l'Europe s'est trouvée alors débordée
des images nous restent de cette année
2015 et des années qui ont immédiatement
suivi le drame des naufrages dans la
Méditerranée l'incendie du camp de Moréa
la solidarité est démontrée par les
populations locales mais aussi leur
lassitude face à des flux qui ne se
tarissent pas les préoccupations des
autorités publiques en matière de
sécurité et de prévention du terrorisme
etc les sujets ne manquent pas
huit ans après
ou en sommes-nous nous avons voulu avec
Estelle Youssoupha faire un point sur la
question dresser un état des lieux des
enjeux migratoires et vous faire part
d'un certain nombre de pistes de
réflexion et de recommandations
notre objectif en nous appelant à cette
mission d'information était de nous
concentrer sur deux jaunes géographiques
le flanc sud de l'Union européenne donc
d'abord allant des îles Canaries
jusqu'au Balkans occidentaux en passant
par l'Italie et la Grèce et puis Mayotte
ensuite qui s'est vu reconnaître en 2014
le statut de région ultra périphérique
de l'Union européenne et qui constitue
elle aussi en ce sens une frontière sud
de l'Union le champ des questions
migratoires est extrêmement vaste et il
nous fallait impérativement délimiter le
champ des travaux c'est pourquoi outre
cette délimitation géographique nous
avons choisi de concentrer nos travaux
sur des migrations irrégulières c'est à
dire sur les personnes qui franchissent
les frontières européennes sans document
de voyage visa ou titre de séjour nos
travaux ont porté sur trois grands axes
premièrement nous sommes intéressés au
volume des flux et aux routes empruntées
en essayant d'esquisser des
anticipations pour les mois et années à
venir nous avons abordé ensuite le défi
de la gestion des années à venir
et les frontières en jeu de plus en plus
stratégiques avec le rôle central des
volumes aux états de première entrée
enfin nous nous sommes penchés sur les
réponses apportées à ces nouveaux enjeux
nous avons ici fait un point sur le
fameux pacte européen sur la migration
et l'asile va se projeter de réforme du
droit européen à la matière dans les
négociations s'éternisent depuis 4 ans
nous n'avons pas traité ou seulement de
façon incidente des questions
fondamentales comme la traversée de la
Manche la protection temporaire des
déplacées Ukrainiens les conditions
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile ou
encore l'intégration des réfugiés des
étrangers en situation régulière toute
question essentielle mais qui ont fait
ou feront l'objet d'autres travaux
parlementaires
notre premier constat c'est que après
une période de reflux liée à la crise
sanitaire les flux migratoires sont très
fortement repartis à la hausse plus de
330 000 entrées irrégulières dans
l'Union européenne ont été enregistrés
en 2022 une augmentation de plus de 65%
par rapport à l'année précédente il ne
s'agit que des entrées enregistrées
toutes n'étant pas détecté cette reprise
se répercute dans le nombre de demandes
d'asile déposées plus de 137 000
nouvelles demandes ont été enregistrées
en France en 2022 en hausse de plus de
31% par rapport à 2021
l'OFPRA anticipe pour 2023 un chiffre
d'au moins 160 000 demandes d'asile
déposées devant lui rappelons que selon
le rapport de la Cour des comptes plus
de 96% des déboutés du droit d'asile
demeure sur le territoire français
malgré le rejet de leur demande
le ministre de l'Intérieur estimé en
novembre dernier un chiffre compris
entre 600 000 et 900 000 le nombre
d'étrangers séjourna aujourd'hui est
régulièrement sur le territoire national
s'agissant des routes empruntées par les
migrants celle des Balka occidentaux est
devenu en 2022 la première route au sud
de l'Europe avec 145 600 franchissement
irréguliers en augmentation de 136% par
rapport à 2021 elle est utilisée surtout
par des Syriens des Afghans et des Turcs
la deuxième route est celle de la
Méditerranée centrale avec plus de 1000
entrées régulières en 2022 en hausse de
51% par rapport à 2021 elle est
empruntée essentiellement par des
Égyptiens des Tunisiens et des banglades
notre deuxième grand constat c'est celui
de la très forte accélération à la fin
de l'année 2022 et au cours des premiers
mois de 2023 des arrivées par cette
route près de 45 000 migrants sont
arrivés irrégulièrement par voie
maritime en Italie entre le 1er janvier
et le 8 mai 2023 contre environ 12000
sur la même période en 2022 soit une
augmentation de 279%
. ce n'est certainement qu'un début car
la saison des traversées depuis la
Tunisie est la Libye se concentre
surtout sur la période qui va du mois de
mai au mois d'octobre
cette augmentation exponentielle
explique au moins en partie la nervosité
des autorités italiennes dont nous avons
pu prendre la mesure lors de notre
déplacement à Rome leur ont été bien
reçu je vous rassure mais vous savez que
celle-ci ont suspendu en décembre
dernier des transferts Dublin
les renvois vers l'Italie des demandeurs
d'asile entrer dans l'Union européenne
via ce pays
elles ont motivé cette suspension par
l'état de saturation de leur centre
d'accueil notre pays de son côté avait
suspendu dès novembre 2022 ces
opérations de relocalisation de
punitalie vers notre pays à la suite de
la fameuse affaire dite de l'Océane
Viking ces opérations de relocalisation
et de relocation était effectuées
jusqu'à lors dans le cadre du mécanisme
volontaire de solidarité mis en place
par l'UE en juin 2022 pour soulager les
états de première entrée
ces épisodes illustrent les défis
majeurs que posent les flux migratoires
actuelles à la solidarité européenne et
le coin qu'il risque d'enfoncer entre
les états de première entrée et se
destinataire des mouvements secondaires
nous avons relevé avec Estelle
Youssoupha l'agacement pour ne pas dire
plus des états de première entrée
principalement l'Italie la Grèce est
Chypre qui soulignent que les autres
États membres se satisfont fort bien de
leur avoir en quelque sorte déléguer la
mission de contrôle des frontières
extérieures de l'Union européenne il
souligne aussi qu'ils ne sont que 5 avec
Malte et aussi l'Espagne a porté tout le
poids de ce premier accueil alors que
les efforts dit de solidarité sont
répartis entre les 22 autres États
membres
autre fait qui doit nous alerter les
deux premières nationalités parmi les
arrivants par voie maritimes en Italie
sont des francophones les Ivoiriens et
les Guinéens or ces Ivoiriens et ses
guinéens ne souhaitent pas rester en
Italie même si celle-ci en sa qualité
d'état de première accueil enregistre
leur demande d'asile ces migrants
souhaitent rejoindre la France où il
existe déjà des diaspora ivoirienne et
guinéennes c'est le troisième grand
constat de ce rapport comme la déclarait
le directeur général de l'Office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration on a une augmentation des
tentatives de passage à travers les
Alpes parce que justement ce sont pour
beaucoup d'entre elles des nationalités
où on parle français serait donc
illusoire de penser que ces arrivées par
la Méditerranée centrale ne sont qu'un
problème italien
s'agissant de la troisième route celle
de la Méditerranée orientale elle est
elle aussi en aide augmentation mais
avec des chiffres qui ne présentent pas
ou pas encore caractère extrême il y a
quelques années la situation dans les
îles grecques n'est donc plus du tout la
même que celle qu'on a pu connaître dans
les années qui ont suivi la crise de
2015 une chose que nous avons
découvertes et qui est encore méconnue
c'est l'émergence d'une forte émigration
palestinienne en provenant soit du Liban
soit de Gaza via l’égypte les
Palestiniens constituent la première
nationalité arrivée dans les îles de la
mer Égée pour l'année 2022 et le premier
trimestre de l'année 2023 les routes de
la Méditerranée
occidentale et de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
reste quant à elle encore relativement
sous contrôle
la crise des réfugiés de 2015 était
clairement liée à des facteurs
géopolitiques guerre en Syrie extension
de l'État islamique déstabilisation de
l'Irak et de l'Afghanistan renversement
du régime de Kadhafi et guerre civile
qui a suivi
tout indique que l'augmentation très
fort des mouvements migratoires à
laquelle on assiste aujourd'hui ne sera
pas ponctuel mais qu'elle sera bien
durable il existe en effet désormais des
facteurs de migration particulièrement
prégnants changements climatique et la
sécheresse en Afrique la stabilité et la
sécurité au sud du Sahara les
incertitudes sur l'évolution de la
Tunisie les risques pointés par le Fond
Monétaire International de voir de
nombreux pays émergents ou en
développement basculer dans une crise de
la dette souveraine en 2023
il ne faut donc pas s’attendre à un
ralentissement des flux migratoires dans
les mois et années qui viennent très
concrètement nous appelons au maintien
s'agissant de notre pays de la
réintroduction temporaire du contrôle
aux frontières intérieur de l'espace
Schengen de surcroît dans le contexte
particulier de la préparation de la
Coupe du monde de rugby et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
face à ces perspectives où en est
l'Union européenne à la suite de la
crise des migrantes 2015 la présidente
de la Commission européenne Ursula avant
d'alleren a proposé en juillet 2019 la
conclusion d'un nouveau pacte sur
l'immigration et la ville ce pacte visé
à modifier un certain nombre de
directives et règlement en vigueur et à
les compléter par de nouveaux textes
s'agissant en particulier de réformer le
règlement Dublin de 2013 en trouvant un
meilleur équilibre entre la
responsabilité de l'examen de la demande
d'asile un combat à l'état de premier
accueil et la solidarité que doivent lui
montrer les autres États membres par
exemple par un système de relocalisation
de certains demandeurs d'asile le pack
comporte aussi notamment proposition de
règlement établissant un filtrage des
migrants irréguliers aux frontières
extérieures avec à la clé un objet
d'identification et de contrôle
sanitaire et de sécurité je citerai
aussi la proposition de règlement
relative à la procédure d'asile à la
frontière prévoyant une procédure
d'examen accélérée et sur place pour les
personnes se caractérisant par un faible
taux d'octroi
de la protection si ce pack va dans le
bon sens et comporte des mesures
ambitieuses les discussions s'éternisent
malheureusement depuis 2020 la
présidence française au premier semestre
2022 a permis à déblocage en obtenant un
accord sur une approche dite graduelle
visant à négocier en priorité certains
volets clés du pacte et non les textes
dans leur globalité de nouveaux progrès
ont été enregistrés sous la présidence
tchèque au second semestre 2022 n'en
reste pas moins que ce jour à ce jour
pardon un seul texte a été
définitivement adopté le règlement
relatif à l'agence de l'Union européenne
pour l'asile
à 10 mois des élections européennes de
2024 et de la fin du mandat de l'actuel
commission il est grand temps de
parvenir à un accord en espérant que les
États ne se contenteront pas de textes à
minima et adopteront des dispositifs
suffisamment opérationnels pour être
efficaces nous appelons dans nos
recommandations à ce que la France pèse
de tout son poids en ce sens je vous
remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Madame Youssoupha
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je voudrais d'abord
sincèrement remercier l'administrateur
Bruno Legrain pour son remarquable
travail qui me permet aujourd'hui de
vous présenter ce rapport avec mon
estime et collègue Marc angélique
remercier également ma collaboratrice
Aéria Abdallah qui a organisé la mission
à Mayotte mais aussi les autorités
locales qui nous sont accueillies et nos
ambassades françaises en Grèce et en
Italie qui se sont mobilisés pour notre
accueil je veux commencer par souligner
que les États n'ont pas attendu la
finalisation du pacte européen sur la
migration et l'asile pour agir et
s'engager dans une coopération avec les
états de départ et de transit ces
partenariats peuvent être conclus sur
une base bilatérale aux multilatérale
selon les cas l'espace a ainsi noué une
bonne coopération avec le Maroc et le
Sénégal qui a nettement permis de
réduire le flux l'Autriche deuxième pays
européen en nombre de demandeurs d'asile
par habitant a conclu des accords avec
le Maroc qui ont été rendus publics en
février dernier la France grâce à elle
conclut des accords de gestion concertés
des flux migratoires avec plusieurs pays
africains des accords de réadmission ont
également été conclus par l'euro l'Union
européenne nous soulignons dans notre
rapport l'efficacité de ce type de
coopération et appelons à multiplier ses
partenariats dans un esprit d'exigence
il faut en effet pouvoir discuter
simultanément de l'aide publique au
développement et de la délivrance des
visas mais aussi de la surveillance des
autoritoriales du rapatriement des
migrants interceptés de la réadmission
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
et de la délivrance et laisser passer
consulaires je considère pour ma part
que la clause de revoyure de ses
partenariats est impérative pour
vérifier le respect des engagements pris
l'esprit de cette mission sur les
questions migratoires étaient d'établir
un comparatif entre territoires
insulaires frontaliers qui font face il
me semble à un afflux migratoire pour
examiner les politiques d'accueil mises
en place et les difficultés les réponses
apportées
nous avons pu effectuer un déplacement à
Lampedusa cette petite île sicilienne de
20 km² et devenu pour beaucoup de
migrants la première porte d'entrée dans
l'Union européenne selon l'agence de
l'Union européenne pour l'asile les
arrivées à l'empedusa ont augmenté
d'environ 300% pendant les quatre
premiers mois de 2023 comme l'a expliqué
mon collègue Marc Angeli le mois dernier
les garde-côte et la garde des finances
italiennes ont au cours d'une seule
semaine ramener entre 50 et 55 bateaux à
Lampedusa soit 2000 personnes secourus
en 7 jours construit en 2015 le hotspot
de Lampedusa héberge à l'heure actuelle
quatre fois plus de migrants que sa
capacité normale d'accueil qui est de
400 places j'ai été frappé je dois le
souligner par la remarquable
organisation mise en place par les
autorités italiennes pour secourir les
migrants et des lits à faire face à
cette afflux migratoire hors du commun
une procédure bien huilée qui permet de
prendre en charge les migrants pour
qu'il reste un minimum de temps dans le
hotspot de Lampedusa et les transformer
en quelques heures voire quelques jours
maximum vers la Sicile ou sur le la
péninsule italienne moyennant la
mobilisation de deux ferry par jour et
le recours si nécessaire à des avions
militaires de transport la capacité du
hotspot de Lampedusa va par ailleurs
être porté à 1250 places et sa gestion
confiée à la Croix Rouge italienne alors
qu'elle relevait jusqu'à présent du
secteur privé
j'ai également pu me rendre en Grèce sur
l'île de Samos qui se trouve elle aussi
en première ligne les arrivées à Samo
sont beaucoup moins nombreuses qu'à
lampe et 12a là-bas un centre d'accueil
en dur a été construit sur fonds
européen avec des transferts réguliers
vers le continent je n'ai plus qu'être
frappé en tant que député de Mayotte de
la comparaison à faire avec le
département français de l'océan Indien
que je représente ici et comme on a
cours rapporteur l'a indiqué Mayotte est
officiellement depuis janvier 2014 une
région ultra périphérique de l'Union
européenne en regardant ce qui a été
fait en Italie et en Grèce on ne peut
que constater que Mayotte n'a pas
bénéficié c'est pour le moins que l'on
puisse dire de la même solidarité de la
part de l'État comme de l'Europe elle
est pourtant elle aussi en première
ligne face au flux migratoire massif
vous le savez en provenance de leur
immense majorité de l'Union des Comores
séparé de Mayotte de quelques 70 km
96% des entrées irrégulières détectées
en 2022 à Mayotte concerne des
ressortissants comoriens on constate
certes l'émergence d'une nouvelle
immigration originaire de la région des
Grands Lacs
principalement de la République
démocratique du Congo du Rwanda et du
Burundi qui arrive en transitant par la
Tanzanie et Madagascar le but de ces
migrants est souvent de déposer une
demande d'asile à Mayotte les migrants
qui arrivent sur des canaux de pêche
rapide équipées d'un ou deux moteurs
équipés quoi ça appelait quoi ça quoi ça
on estime qu'une centaine de migrants
arrivent quotidiennement à Mayotte
pour revenir sur mon territoire je dois
souligner que l'immigration de masse en
provenance des Comores à des effets
dramatiques sur place l'île connaît une
explosion d'immographique sans précédent
avec une multiplication de la population
par 4 entre 85 et 2020
54% de la population à moins de 20 ans
le système scolaire est totalement
débordé et à recours à un système de
rotation des classes pour utiliser les
mêmes locaux les personnes non affiliées
à la sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
représente près de 50% des séjours au
centre hospitalier de Mayotte et plus de
90% des consultations dans les services
de Protection Maternelle et infantiles à
cet écart nous recommandons la mise en
place à Mayotte de l'aide médicale
d'État qui permettrait de séparer la
dépense des soins pour les étrangers du
budget de la santé dévoluent aux assurés
sociaux
vous le savez abrite le plus grand
bidonville de France les constructions
illégales et les plantations sauvages
provoquent des coulées debout qui
détruisent le lagon qui est pourtant clé
pour la sécurité environnementale de
Mayotte Mayotte qui est le département
le plus déforesté de France la
déforestation couplée à l'explosion
démocratie qui échappe à toute
projection administrative alimente un
manque de ressources en eau potable et
des coupures d'eau quotidiennes il est
impossible ne pas parler de
l'hyperviolence qui a surgi sur notre
île avec des agressions allant jusqu'à
des actes de barbarie et des mutilations
souvent commises par des bandes de
jeunes issus de l'immigration et
instrumentalisés par leurs parents
lorsque les autorités veulent procéder à
des expulsions
ce n'est pas nous les rapporteurs qui
exagérant ni les élus mahorés c'est la
réalité une réalité officiellement
rapportée par six inspections générales
de l'État un rapport qui vient d'être
rendu public par le jeu cite de service
public déjà saturés de pression
considérable sur l'habitat et
l'environnement avec cette conclusion
Dans l'hypothèse d'un maintien des flux
migratoires au niveau actuel à Mayotte
la situation deviendra explosive
tout ceci montre bien que la politique
menée par les gouvernements successifs
pour Mayotte et loin d'être suffisante
elle repose d'abord sur des spécialités
juridiques des exceptions pour Mayotte
touchant par exemple au droit de la
nationalité qui vise à rendre plus
restrictive les conditions d'acquisition
de la nationalité française mais on voit
que ces spécificités n'ont pas eu
d'effets dissuasif la politique de
l'État reposant ensuite sur une
politique d'interception et
d'éloignement en 2022 plus de 25000
personnes ont été reconduites aux
Comores ces reconduites sont
indispensables mais elles n'ont une
portée que limitée en effet seule une
fraction d'équatsa est interceptée et
les personnes éloignées reviennent
quasiment systématiquement
parfois quelques heures seulement après
la crise migratoire à Mayotte n'ira
qu'en empirant si des axes forts si des
actes forts ne sont pas posés sauf à
croire ce que les rapporteurs ici se
refusent que l'espoir se crée de
certains responsables politiques à Paris
ne soit que de garlas la population
mahoraise ne finissent par se résigner à
la séparation avec la France et que les
Comores et réussi leur pari de
renversement démographique
face à cette situation notre rapport
avance plusieurs propositions concrètes
je citerai les principales nous
proposons d'abord d'appliquer à Mayotte
la circulaire dit tobira du 3 mai 2013
qui prévoit la répartition sur
l'ensemble du territoire national des
mineurs étrangers isolés les services de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance du conseil
départemental de Mayotte sont en effet
totalement débordés malgré le triplement
de la capacité d'accueil il accuse
toujours un déficit de place pour ces
mineurs qui pourraient être réparties
dans d'autres départements français
il nous semble urgent de mettre en place
l'aide médicale d'État à Mayotte son
absence a aujourd'hui un effet concret
celui de saturé le seul hôpital de
Mayotte et les services de Protection
Maternelle et infantiles par les
consultations d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière je vous rappelle que Mayotte
est un désert médical que de nombreux
mahorés sont très pauvres et qu'il est
impossible de laisser perdurer cette
concurrence indigne entre Français et
étrangers pour l'accès aux soins à la
santé
la Défenseur des droits a dénoncé la
difficulté d'exercer son droit à la
santé à Mayotte la prise en compte du
facteur migratoire dans cette équation
est capitale en mettant en place le
système réfléchi à cet effet dans
l'Hexagone nous invitons également à
mettre fin au restrictions territoriales
qui s'appliquent au visa ainsi qu'à la
plupart des titres de séjour dont
bénéficient les étrangers à Mayotte les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
doivent ainsi demander à un visa pour
aller dans l'Hexagone ou dans un autre
département aux régions d'outre-mer ou
encore le reste de l'espace Schengen
alors qu'ils sont régularisés à Mayotte
ces restrictions ont pour effet de fixer
indéfiniment la population fixe la
population migrante dans notre île de
375 km². il y a là une grande hypocrisie
l'État ne se donne pas les moyens
d'arrêter l'immigration comorienne à
Mayotte mais elle n'assume pas pour
autant d'en répartir la charge au reste
du pays
nous invitons aussi à poser la question
du maintien de l'aide publique française
au développement envers les Comores tant
que celles-ci n'auront pas reconnu
Mayotte française n'auront pas abandonné
leur revendications territoriale
éprouvaient dans les faits leur capacité
à surveiller leurs côtes et prévenir les
départs il nous paraît essentiel de
faire respecter la frontière maritime
entre la France et l'Union des Comores
en consacrant les moyens nécessaires à
empêcher la pénétration des bateaux
étrangers dans les eaux françaises sans
préjudice bien sûr du droit de la mer et
du secours au navire en danger
la France devrait également innoble pour
mettre en oeuvre cette politique résolue
demandez un soutien fort de l'Union
européenne par le biais notamment des
fonds européens du fond asile migration
intégration ainsi que des agences
spécialisés pour Mayotte on sait que
l'agence Frontex est monté en puissance
elle devrait pouvoir apporter un
véritable soutain à Mayotte tant le dans
le domaine des retours que celui de la
surveillance de la protection des la
frontières maritime je vous rappelle que
Frontex intervient de plus en plus dans
des pays non limitrophes de l'Union
européenne notamment africains il est
pour nous il est pour nous incompressif
incompréhensible que Frontex soit
déployé aux frontières sénégalaises ou
mauritanienne mais ne soit pas déployés
à Mayotte voilà en conclusion un
panorama des principaux enjeux qui nous
attendent au sud de l'Europe comme dans
cet extrême sud quel océan Indien nous
espérons que ce rapport contribuera à
vous éclairer sur ces enjeux et nous y
préparer
je vous remercie
je vous remercie infiniment c'était un
rapport très intéressant évidemment les
groupes politiques vont s'exprimer la
première à intervenir c'est Amélia la
graphie pour le groupe des sens merci
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je tiens tout d'abord à
remercier mes collègues pour ce rapport
pour ses éclairages particulièrement
intéressants et très approfondi sur ces
enjeux migratoires ce rapport aborde les
défis auxquels notre pays et l'Union
européenne doit faire face en matière
d'accueil des réfugiés de traitements
des demandes de titres de séjour ou de
respect de nos frontières mais il
souligne également l'instrumentalisation
de la question migratoire par certains
pays afin de faire pression sur les
États européens cette situation est
d'autant plus complexe que l'importance
des flux migratoires des déplacements de
population et des personnes cherchant
asiles devraient malheureusement
augmenter en raison des crises des
conflits persistants mais également et
surtout du fait du changement climatique
dans ce contexte et parce que ce
télescope en elle l'ensemble des
éléments que je viens d'évoquer je
souhaiterais aborder aujourd'hui la
situation de Mayotte que vous avez
particulièrement décrit madame la député
l'ile reçoit comme vous l'avez très bien
expliqué chaque année plusieurs milliers
de migrants situations irrégulière
provenant en grande partie de l'Union
des Comores mais toutefois comme vous
l'avez aussi souligné une nouvelle
immigration apparaît de la région des
Grands Lacs mais aussi de Madagascar or
l'intensité de ces flux impact
négativement la population établie à
Mayotte et c'est très peu de le dire
avec des conséquences sur
l'approvisionnement en eau la densité la
démographie les systèmes de santé et
système éducatifs mais plus marquant
encore les flux d'immigration en
provenance de des Comores font l'objet
d'une instrumentalisation de l'État
comorien qui revendique toujours sa
souveraineté sur Mayotte dernièrement
l'opération de wombouchou visant à
réduire l'habitat illégal et un salut
libre à débouché sur une crise
diplomatique entre la France et l'Union
des Comores cette dernière a appelé à
l'annulation de l'opération et refuse de
réintégrer ses ressortissants de passage
en France début même le président des
Comores Azali Assoumani a réaffirmé la
position de son pays rappelant que la
constitution de l'Union des Comores
reconnaît une Mayotte comorienne et
c'est vrai que je me suis rendu deux
fois dans ce pays de ma circonscription
et on y voit partout des panneaux des
quatre par trois qui rappelle que
Mayotte et comorienne ainsi je
souhaiterais savoir comment selon vous
la France peut sortir de cet impasse
diplomatique
il me semble que c'est une question qui
va plutôt madame Youssoupha
tu veux couper ton
non il y a quelqu'un qui merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur Président chers collègues
alors pour aller rapidement je pense que
l'opération en bouchou a eu un effet blé
masque et que pour celles et ceux qui
ignoraient la stratégie comorienne le
discours du président azali qui s'est
répandue dans les médias à Paris a quand
même bien clarifié pour émi fin à
l'hypocrisie des années de coopération
avec les Comores qui et pour moi
remettre en cause la stratégie du Quai
d'Orsay qui dit qu'il faut enjamber la
question de de la souveraineté et de la
revendication comorienne et qu'il faut
travailler avec Moroni pour moi là on a
clairement une situation évidente où on
prouve que ce n'est pas possible je
tiens à souligner quand même que les
propos du président azali et des
autorités sont extrêmement graves
puisqu'il s'agit d'un gérance c'est un
État étranger qui refuse une opération
de dans l'ordre sur son territoire c'est
évidemment contre revenir aux accords
qui ont été passés entre la France et
les Comores puisque contre 150 millions
d'euros les Comores se sont engagés
d'aide au développement les Comores se
sont engagés à
comment dire lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine alors qu'elle
l'instrumentalise moi je pense qu'il est
temps de sortir de la neige acheter
qu'il est temps aussi de sortir de
l'hypocrisie parce que je pense que
beaucoup de gens ici comprennent ce qui
se passe mais on choisit de fermer les
yeux et de sacrifier Mayotte pour une
alliance avec les Comores je rappelle
également quand même que sauf à ce qu'on
est une attitude lucide c'est-à-dire
qu'on chiffre nos objectifs de lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine opérée
par les Comores et que quand elle ne
répondent pas à leurs engagements on
ferme le robinet des aides je ne vois
pas comment ça peut changer je ne vois
pas comment plus comment on peut
continuer à considérer qu'on peut
coopérer avec un état qui ne reconnaît
pas nos frontières je je ma
cognitivement je ne comprends pas c'est
résultat qui va signer un accord de
coopération pour lutter contre une
immigration quand les signes qui
l'encourage on en est là aujourd'hui
donc on doit nous à Paris je pense que
les autorités comoriennes ont clairement
dit qu'elles ne se remettaient pas en
question qu'elle n'abandonnait pas leur
revendications sur Mayotte c'est à nous
de changer de discours c'est à nous de
dire en fait il n'y aura pas d'être
française aux Comores tant que vous ne
reconnaissez pas Mayotte française et
ensuite on pourra discuter de la lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine mais à
mon avis cette lecture qui a longtemps
été celle qui a prévalué à Paris de dire
c'est juste une question de misère c'est
juste une question de difficulté
médicale que je ne nie pas la pauvreté
aux Comores est une réalité le désert
les difficultés pour accéder aux soins
aux Comores sont une réalité comme pour
l'enseignement mais ça ne justifie pas
de nier la revendication de Moroni sur
Mayotte je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues il y a une des
recommandations que nous formulons qui
est qui est assez clair c'est un
changement de doctrine de notre pays en
matière d'appréhension de l'immigration
et notamment de mettre de la
géostratégie et de la géopolitique
notamment à travers la notion de des
protéines problématiques
migratoires c'est une question de
défense nationale également parce que je
le rappelle là vous avez l'exemple qui a
été
fourni par ma collègue qui a le vit sur
son territoire mais depuis plusieurs
années des régimes politiques utilisent
la pression migratoire comme une arme
une arme diplomatique vous l'avez eu
avec le président lucaschenko notamment
lors de sa réélection qui avait été vous
le savez contesté par les organisations
internationales par l'Union européenne à
l'époque le président Lukachenko ferait
des visas de tourisme aux Irakiens
afin de les faire passer ensuite par ses
frontières et parmi et parmi c'est ces
personnes il y avait des combattants du
Jihad vous avez également des pressions
qui ont une frontière touristique de
destination c'était évident première
ordre vous avez également vous avez
également la pression sur la Grèce que
la Turquie fait jouer je rappelle quand
même que de nombreux Syriens à l'époque
sont passés par la frontière turque et
on a utilisé cette pression pour des
questions territoriales qui rendent les
rapports entre Turquie et
Grèce difficile depuis des décennies je
pourrais également vous parler parce
qu'avait fait le dictateur moins
marcadafi à l'époque pour faire pression
sur l'Italie ou encore d'autres
mouvements
que vous pouvez voir parce qu'en réalité
aujourd'hui la pression migratoire est
une arme est une arme géostratégique
alors ce que nous essayons de proposer
dans ce
[Musique]
monsieur pour le rassemblement national
Monsieur François je vous remercie
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues plus d'1,2 millions de
personnes non européennes ont reçu un
premier titre de séjour en France lors
du premier mandat d'Emmanuel Macron il y
a les discours il y a les faits en
moyenne 255 675 nouveaux titres de
séjour ont été attribués chaque année
entre 2017 et 2021 c'est 17,5% de plus
que lors du grand Kena de François
Hollande qui comptait lui 217 000
premier titre de séjour donné à des
ressortissants non européens cerise sur
le gâteau 320 000 titres de séjour ont
été délivrés pour la première fois
uniquement en 2022 c'est 17% de plus
qu'en 2021 et à cela s'ajoute évidemment
l'immigration illégale qui n'est
comptabilisée dans aucune des études
officielles on arrive donc à des
chiffres qui sont faramineux avec des
impacts que notre société peut connaître
donc tension sur le marché de l'emploi
insécurité impôts pression sur notre
système de sécurité sociale et la liste
est bien longue cette situation
évidemment à mettre en perspective avec
le rapport qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui l'immigration massive que
subissent nos compatriotes Mahoré n'est
évidemment pas tolérable et nous le font
savoir de manière quotidienne
précédemment c'est en 2021 à Ceuta ça a
été mentionné en Espagne que l'Espagne a
fait face à une immigration
ultraviolente qu'ils ont de plus en plus
de mal à endiguer en juin 2022 c'est
près de 2000 migrants qui ont tenté de
passer la frontière de Melilla causant
des morts bousculade et évidemment des
dégâts matériels un commenceurable cette
immigration les Français la refusent la
semaine passée dans un sondage de l'Ifop
ils sont 70% à se prononcer pour la
réforme de la de la Constitution afin de
diminuer l'immigration comme toujours le
peuple veut mais le gouvernement
successifs
ignore alors ayez donc le courage de
proposer un référendum comme le propose
Marine Le Pen alors Monsieur le rappeur
monsieur le rapporteur ma question
s'adresse à vous ce rapport est le
reflet d'une réalité qui a été trop
longtemps
occultée à savoir que l'immigration
massive éclandestine et néfaste pour
notre pays ma question est donc simple
ne se le rapporteur la majorité
présidentielle
sont-elles encore longtemps
ignorer l'appel des Français et
évidemment stopper de manière concrète
l'immigration massives au lieu de
l'encourager comme votre gouvernement le
fait je vous remercie évidemment
monsieur Marc Angel il y a plusieurs
casquettes mais là c'est en tant que
rapporteur de cette commission ils n'ont
pas en tant que président de groupe
qu'il est ici mais il vous répondra
simplement dire volontiers quand même
d'autant plus que
si je ne m'abuse monsieur le Président
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
une panoplie de de propositions que vous
pouvez évoquer n'a aucun rapport avec
les travaux que nous menons à la
commission des affaires étrangères pour
être plutôt avoir un débat en commission
des lois
de masse et d'ailleurs le texte que le
gouvernement veut mettre sur la table et
soumis à votre approbation ou à votre
désapprobation aujourd'hui de quoi
parlons-nous nous parlons en commission
des affaires étrangères de mouvement
migratoires il y a des chiffres même si
on parle d'homme et de femmes c'est
important quand même d'évoquer aussi
à caractère humain de ces mouvements
c'est important je
persiste à penser que il ne faut jamais
se départir de cela
donc des chiffres des mouvements des
évolutions et également la problématique
concernant la participation de la France
à des traités des traités au sein de
l'Union européenne qui doivent être j'en
fais aujourd'hui la demande révisée
mais également des traités bilatéraux
que la France a avec des pays qui ne
sont pas respectés
et il faut aussi avoir le courage de le
dire alors c'est pas dans le rapport
mais aujourd'hui si on veut
véritablement se poser des questions les
bonnes questions la contribution en tant
que député élu président d'un groupe
parlementaire de manière accessoire
peut-être aussi devant nous avoir une
réflexion calme posée sereine mais
néanmoins réaliste par rapport à ce
nombre de traités que nous avons depuis
les années 60 notamment
avec des pays qui sont proches de nous
dans notre histoire mais également avec
des Français issus de ces pays
je parle naturellement de l'Algérie
c'est une réalité concrète en tout cas
moi ce qui me concerne vous savez je
sais pas pour j'ai pas pour habitude de
mettre mes convictions dans ma poche il
y a un débat qui est ouvert aujourd'hui
sur le front de l'immigration nous avons
des discussions qui a sont présentes sur
la table un groupe parlementaire de
notre Assemblée nationale à formuler
deux propositions une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
qui veut être débattue vous connaissez
toutes et tous mes chers collègues la
difficulté de faire passer une
modification de la Constitution a eu
égard aux règles qui s'imposent à nous
mais également une proposition des
propositions de loi ordinaire et je m'en
réfère à ce qu'a dit publiquement le
ministre de l'Intérieur sur un certain
nombre de sujets auxquels vous avez fait
référence dans votre question les
discussions sont ouvertes et à titre
personnel En tant que président de
groupe parlementaire il m'a demandé il
m'a demandé au président de groupe
parlementaire de participer à des
discussions avec les groupes qui
souhaitent parler de ce sujet et je
conclurai là-dessus oui ce sujet il est
important les Français attendent des
réponses peuvent pas se satisfaire de
parole mais d'actes
mais je vais me permettre de
d'intervenir
je pense qu'effectivement
l'un des sujets que vous soulevez même
si c'est ne partage pas les mêmes idées
c'est la question de l'acceptabilité
moi je suis insulaire comme comme mon
collègue cooporteur on est allé sur des
îles pour les continentaux c'est très
difficile de comprendre qu'un une île
c'est un espace fini et en fait on peut
pas accueillir tenter plus
on a une tradition pardon mais on a une
tradition d'accueil partout c'est c'est
le cœur de l'humanité mais en fait sur
des îles la contrainte elle est beaucoup
plus forte et moi j'ai été frappée de la
de la similarité de ce qu'il s'est passé
dans les îles en Italie comme en Grèce
par rapport à ce que nous avons nous à
Mayotte c'est à dire des îles qui ont
accueilli tenté plus qui ont fait un
effort d'hospitalité
d'humanité de solidarité qui est inouï
dans l'Hexagone 50% de la population
étrangère c'est certainement pas
acceptable mais à Mayotte c'est ce qu'on
vit et de nous faire traiter de
xénophobe qu'on nous ferme la porte
c'est exactement le discours que nous
ont tenu des Grecs et les Italiens qui
subissent très très mal le discours qui
que l'on verse sur eux le regard qui est
porté sur eux c'est extrêmement
douloureux de la même manière et vous
l'avez soulevé oui la question de
l'accueil de population migrantes et de
saturation des services publics de
difficultés d'accueil de prédation qui
peut y avoir sur le foncier provoque des
violences
et pour nous cette sonnette d'alarme
c'est pour dire on doit agir avant qu'il
y ait des violences ça c'est clair il y
a eu des violences en Grèce il y a eu
des violences en Italie et nous à
Mayotte on connaît aussi des violences
et donc l'angélisme ne fait pas avancer
et j'espère je suis pas du tout
convaincue que ce serait ce sera
possible mais j'espère je souhaite
vraiment de tout mon coeur qu'on arrive
à avoir un débat parce que les
projections de l'ONU sont claires on va
vers des flux migratoires de plus en
plus important pour le continent
européen donc soit on est à la hauteur
de la mission qui est la nôtre
c'est-à-dire d'anticiper et d'avoir une
discussion qui est sereine et on tire
les leçons des crises que subissent les
zones les plus exposées qui sont en fait
à l'avant-poste de ce que certains
envisagent pour le continent soit on
continue de mettre la tête dans le sable
et d'être sur discussions partisanes
complètement stérile qui en fait
n'avance pas mais vraiment moi je peux
pas en conscience avoir cette discussion
ici et ne pas vous dire que ce que j'ai
vu en Italie en Grèce a été très
similaire avec ce que moi je vis à
Mayotte et que ça interpelle parce que
ces pays ont fait au niveau central des
révolutions Copernic iennes dans leur
vision de l'immigration et que nous on
doit aussi s'interroger sans quoi les
les pouvoirs politiques sont acculés par
des par des sanctions électorales qui ne
conviennent pas enfin je m'excuse
monsieur le Président mais je vais je
vais je vais je ne peux pas ne pas le
mentionner dans pour ces deux pays pour
ces deux pays il y a eu une remise en
cause profonde des règles de l'asile
l'asile est héritée de la deuxième
guerre mondiale c'est la protection des
personnes en danger c'est une tradition
européenne qui est extrêmement
importante et en fait la conséquence de
l'instrumentalisation et de l'abus de
l'asile a fait que l'asile qui devrait
bénéficier aux personnes qui en ont
besoin et considérablement remis en
cause c'est un des effets pervers de
l'absence de prise en cause lucides de
ces questions migratoires je vous
remercie
nous contestera que tout le droit
d'asile a été construit dans un contexte
extraordinairement différent vous avez
raison de le rappeler même si les
conséquences à en tirées ne sont pas
faciles pour la France insoumise madame
abo mongoli monsieur Président mes chers
collègues Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs la France applique des
politiques migratoires toujours plus
rétrogrades ces propos se sont ceux du
Rapporteur spécial sur les droits
humains des migrants au Conseil des
droits de l'homme des Nations Unies à la
lecture de vos conclusions comprend en
substances les griefs formulées par
l'ONU ainsi la gestion des migrations en
Méditerranée et dans l'océan Indien on
appellerait à vos yeux qu'une réponse
sécuritaire la progression des décès
liées à des traversées dangereuses ce
n'est pas vraiment le sujet alors que le
nu recense 450 morts dans la
Méditerranée depuis le début de l'année
la très forte progression du nombre de
déplacés liée au conflit au changement
climatique à l'insécurité alimentaire
donc et qui nécessitait un droit d'asile
ce n'est pas vraiment un sujet non plus
ainsi les déterminants de ces migrations
et les façons de les atténuer sont
à nos yeux survoler dans vos conclusions
les leçons des échecs successifs d'un
traitement purement sécuritaire de
l'immigration de Frontex ne sont pas
vraiment tirés non plus les critiques
émises par les ONG sur les refoulements
illégaux exercés en pleine mer par les
autorités grecques et italiennes sont
peu abordés après tout tant que c'est
pas en France ce n'est pas notre
problème si on vous suit l'Europe
devrait généraliser la sous-traitance
des flux migratoires le sud de la
Méditerranée serait donc un sas une
antichambre de l'espace européen
moyennant finance et la possibilité d'un
traitement par des pays tiers plus
éloignés et évoqués selon nous ce ne
sont pas des sources d'inspiration
acceptable gérer un flux une masse
informe en oubliant au passage
l'humanité la dimension sociale ça ne
correspond pas à notre vision et la
traduction de cette conception pour nous
c'est cette opération d'un bouchon que
vous aviez évoqué qui ne fait
qu'augmenter la crise sociale sans
solution pérenne parce qu'on ne voit pas
de solution pérenne sans planification
pour le développement et pour la
sécurité collective pas de politique de
quels sont selon vous les modalités
d'action de la France au sein de l'ONU
pour plaider pour pour un sommet relatif
à l'océan Indien et à la question de
Mayotte
merci
lequel lequel des deux rapporteurs
commencent madame Youssoupha merci chers
collègues je comprends pas bien
l'utilité d'un sommet de l'ONU à partir
du moment où le pays où le pays ne
reconnaît pas maillot de français en
fait il y a pas besoin d'être 100000
c'est un pays qui décide de reconnaître
le vote d'une population donc je vais
pas me je vais pas aller là dessus je
vais je vais comment dire sur la
question des autres conflits
territoriaux que la France a dans
l'océan Indien elle ne concerne pas des
territoires habités la question de
Mayotte elle est particulière dans
l'océan Indien qui concentre la plus
grande quantité de conflits territoriaux
que la France a issu de la
décolonisation mais Mayotte est le seul
territoire habité et en l'occurrence
nous avons voté
nous avons voté à plusieurs reprises
pour réaffirmer notre notre attachement
la République et notre souhait de rester
français lorsqu'il y a une consultation
pour l'indépendance la moindre des
choses c'est de prendre en compte le
vote le résultat des votes c'est que
Mayotte reste françaises donc on va pas
retourner à l'eau de 50 fois pour aller
dire ce qu'en pense l'ONU c'est la
population qui est concernée qui dit non
sur la question que vous évoquez à
savoir
ou embout je rappelle que 75% des
Français selon un sondage LCI Harris
soutiennent l'opération embout et moi je
remercie nos compatriotes de comprendre
la détresse dans laquelle on est
l'opération en Boussu c'est la simple
application du droit quand on est en
situation irrégulière on est expulsé
quand on contient à la loi qu'on est sur
la liste des 80 personnes qui sont
activement recherchées par la police à
Mayotte et que les forces de l'ordre
procèdent aux arrestations oui on
soutient et quand il s'agit de détruire
de l'habitat clandestin qui occupe des
terrains illégalement qui appartiennent
à la collectivité publique ou à des
personnes privées
il me semble quand même être un minimum
d'appliquer la loi sauf si on considère
que Mayotte et officiellement dans
l'anarchie mais l'application du droit
pour moi n'est pas l'objet d'une d'un
débat par contre sur la question du
logement social je vous rappelle que je
vais répéter la même chose 375 km² à
Mayotte quand vous occupez 15000
hectares illégalement c'est ce terrain
qui doit servir à la construction du
logement social donc moi je n'ai pas de
baguette magique à Mayotte quand les
clandestins occupent du terrain qui est
destiné au logement social je peux pas
les reloger CQFD enfin vous voyez c'est
c'est l'enfer et pavé de bonnes
intentions mais il faut comprendre le
réel le réel c'est que une bonne partie
des terrains qui sont destinés à la
construction de logements sociaux sont
occupés par les clandestins
donc faut bien prendre le problème par
un bout et le laisser faire on le subit
depuis suffisamment longtemps pour
savoir que ça ne marche pas
voilà
j'explicite le soutien à l'opération en
Bouchu et ce pourquoi pour nous c'est
fondamental avant de nous expliquer ce
qu'il faut faire sur Lille c'est de
comprendre la réalité sur le terrain le
logement social n'est pas possible parce
qu'il y a pas de terrain constructible
disponible qu'il est occupé illégalement
donc si vous avez et moi je souligne le
fait que et je vous remercie de vous
engager sur la question de l'aide
médicale d'État comme de l'application
de la circulaire tobira mais si vous
souhaitez prendre les étrangers en
situation irrégulière ou de manière plus
plus carré au niveau légal celles et
ceux qui ont droit au logement c'est à
dire celles et ceux qui sont en
situation régulière qu'ils soient
relogées en attendant dans l'Hexagone je
vous en prie mais moi j'ai jamais
entendu un élu hexagonal me dire Estelle
le relogement c'est une honte à Mayotte
vous n'avez pas de capacité de vos
logements on les prend dans l'Hexagone
en attendant que vous les vous puissiez
construire leur logement vous voyez là
moi je suis tout ouïe je vous remercie
très bien
c'est parler
rien ajouter madame monsieur Marc Angel
vous n'avez rien ajouter bon et bien je
pense que c'est pour les républicains
c'est Monsieur Seget
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mes chers collègues rapporteur
donc Youssoupha et marquant gel pour la
qualité de votre rapport votre rapport
document bien la vague migratoire subie
par Mayotte il faut que notre pays mette
tout en œuvre pour
il faut que notre pays mette tout en
oeuvre pour mettre fin à cette pression
intenable vécue sur note sur votre île
même si cette pression migratoire n'est
malheureusement pas la panache de
Mayotte mais il faut se féliciter
l'opération voire bouchou qui a été
lancé il y a quelques jours concernant
le nombre précis d'habitants à Mayotte
je crois qu'il est urgent de prévoir à
l'échelle nationale comme à Mayotte une
mesure qui applicable en Alsace Moselle
et qui impose à toute habitant de
s'inscrire dans la mairie de son
domicile ce qui permettrait de connaître
précisément et en temps réel le nombre
d'habitants exact dans chaque commune
puisqu'en disposant pas de chiffres
précis il est évidemment très compliqué
de mettre en place des politiques
publiques efficaces concernant votre
proposition de prendre en charge sur
l'ensemble territoire national des
mineurs étrangers isolés mais aussi
l'immigration comorienne là c'est un peu
plus compliqué puisque je crois qu'au
niveau métropolitain et puis je prends
l'exemple de mon département de la
Moselle ou les services du département
ont également beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
gérer l'afflux de mineurs non
accompagnée depuis quelques années enfin
concernant nos rapports avec les Comores
ne disposons pas de moyens de
négociation de pression au niveau
national ou au niveau européen pour que
les Comores cessent leur politique qui
consiste à inciter à leur compatriotes à
venir à Mayotte vous indiquer qu'il faut
se poser la question du maintien de la
République au développement aux Comores
je crois en effet qu'il y a urgence à se
poser cette question et puis enfin
concernant la médicale d'État il y a
l'urgence je pense non seulement à
mettre en place à Mayotte mais également
à redéfinir de manière précise les actes
qui sont prises en charge merci d'avance
en tout cas pour vos réponses
merci beaucoup cher collègue alors pour
l'Aide Sociale à l'Enfance effectivement
la question qui est posée à Mayotte de
manière aiguë appelle à une réflexion
nationale puisque la circulaire tobira
ne fonctionne pas au niveau national ça
je j'en ai bien conscience et l'objet de
nos recommandations c'est d'alerter la
représentation nationale sur le fait
qu'il faut agir le Conseil départemental
appelle à l'aide l'État mais c'est pas
le seul les territoires les départements
de des Alpes-Maritimes sauf erreur sur
la Côte d'Azur qui font face à un afflux
de mineurs isolés ça a été le cas pour
l'Île-de-France ont appelé l'État à la
rescousse et on doit réfléchir
à fortiori parce que l'évolution des
flux migratoires montre que de plus en
plus de mineurs prennent la route de
l'exil c'est à dire que c'est un
problème qui est récent qui va croissant
et qui se pose pour les pour les pays
d'accueil l'Italie les autorités
italiennes nous ont dit que elles
étaient complètement désemparées parce
que jusqu'à présent c'était des mineurs
qui étaient en famille et que depuis
deux ans il arriver des milliers de
mineurs isolés pour lesquels il faut
construire des structures particulières
parce qu'ils sont particulièrement
vulnérables donc ça c'était le sens de
de ma remarque je n'ai pas très bien
compris pour votre formulation ce que
vous disiez par rapport à notre capacité
à agir sur les communs moi je vais juste
rappeler quelques faits
un peu factuel mais qui vous mettront
quand même en perspective le lien entre
la France et les Comores nous avons
notre diplomatie à aider les Comores à
obtenir
un prêt au niveau du FMI de la Banque
mondiale le franc comorien est adossé à
la Banque de France toute l'aide
européenne est gérée par la France pour
les Comores et toute l'aide de
développement bilatéral c'est évidemment
nous qui la version qui excusez moi de
vous rappeler que la quasi majorité de
la population comorienne à la double
nationalité et vit à Paris dans
l'Hexagone vie à Marseille donc les
leviers ils existent
moi je refuse de constater le constat
d'un puissance de dire qu'on ne peut
rien faire contre les Comores je
comprends pas qu'un Lilliputiens
diplomatique nous mène par le bout du
nez ça me paraît incompréhensible
maintenant si on a si on a renoncé c'est
pas grave mais je me permets d'alerter
monsieur Marc Angel vous il faut un peu
accélérer
des chiffres qui sont parfois
incomplet ou inexact c'est une
difficulté à vous le voyez bien même au
niveau du ministère de l'intérieur on
évalue on évalue notamment sur ce qui
concerne l'immigration irrégulière à 900
000 sur des évaluations notamment par
rapport à l'aide médicale d'État mais on
a du mal à savoir puisque par nature ces
personnes qui pénètent sur le territoire
sont pas dotés de papier
peut pas savoir l'orage c'est la
problématique des mineurs non accompagné
donc vous avez vous avez encore
aujourd'hui quand même quelques trous
dans les raquettes si je peux me
permettre l'expression
merci merci Monsieur pour le modem
monsieur Fuchs merci monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup
aux deux rapporteurs pour la qualité de
leur travail pour avoir expliqué
qu'elles étaient les en lequel notre
continent faisait face mais aussi pour
avoir plus spécifiquement intégré les
enjeux de Mayotte mais dans un
raisonnement global c'est ça je pense
intéressant l'intérêt d'un point de vue
l'originalité de ce rapport de pas avoir
traité Mayotte comme un élément
spécifique première élément sur les
questions liées à l'Europe en 2020 la
Commission européenne a décidé de
présenter un plan contre de nombreux
actes législatifs afin de renforcer sa
politique en matière d'Asie et
d'immigration vos travaux montrent bien
la complexité de la situation à un
moment les flux migratoires redémarrent
fortement et au moment aussi où chaque
pays a des situations géographiques et
des enjeux très différents les uns des
autres je voudrais avant de poser ma
question saluer le travail qui a été
effectué lors de la présence française
de l'Union européenne avec une approche
graduelle que vous avez décrit dans
votre rapport et qui était efficacement
reprise par les Tchèques et par les
Suédois première question donc
pensez-vous que un de ces textes un
texte du puisse aboutir prochainement
les changements de majorité probable à
venir dans les certains pays d'Europe
comme l'Espagne sont-ils Natura changer
la donne deuxième élément vous évoquez
la nécessité d'accord plus globaux entre
les pays de départ et de transit en
mettant dans la balance l'aide publique
au développement ou un soutien financier
contre un meilleur contrôle des flux
pensez-vous vraiment que cette situation
cette mesure soit efficace pensez ou pas
qu'une des conséquences de cette mesure
c'est que ces pays iront simplement
chercher un accompagnement et de l'aide
ailleurs sans pour autant être en mesure
de stopper les flux faut-il en
simplifier faut-il conditionner notre
stratégie de coopération à la politique
en matière de maîtrise des flux
migratoires et enfin dernière question
proposée dans votre rapport à la
dilution de l'impact migratoire par une
répartition sur l'ensemble du terroriste
français pour Mayotte en particulier
au-delà de la logique imparable de cette
proposition il y a une conséquence qui
ça peut être négative à cette
proposition je vous interroger là-dessus
pensez pas que l'application de cette
proposition c'est une fait en
conséquence de renoncer globalement à
l'hypothèse du retour parce que si
l'éloignement serait tel que la
perspective de vivre à Saint-Étienne
Dole ou ailleurs même encore ce
aurait un impact dissuif en réalité
l'effet principal de cette mesure c'est
de rendre l'immigration définitive tout
en tout en rendant l'intégration plus
difficile je pense pour l'intéresser
aussi loin de son centre de naissance
on ne revient pas voilà la question
je ne sais pas c'est le président
fut un temps où c'était un paradis du
football en tout cas
plusieurs questions que vous posez voir
je sur l'aboutissement d'un certain
nombre de discussions que notre pays
mène notamment au sein de l'Union
européenne effectivement nous avons pris
du retard mais il y a un certain nombre
de
textes qui peuvent de règlement qui
peuvent passer d'ici la fin de la
mandature de la Commission et du
Parlement européen c'est dans le rapport
et
il y a le règlement qualification et
réinstallation et la directive accueil
semble quasiment stabilisé
en revanche effectivement vous avez vous
avez des difficultés aujourd'hui pour se
mettre d'accord sur un certain nombre de
sujets c'est un sujet d'une très grande
complexité même si vous avez pris le
soin de souligner à juste titre que la
présidence française de 2022 a eu pour
mérite de
d'accélérer le processus d'aller sur ce
sujet le discours de la présidente de la
commission de 2019
reste encore très loin des actes
accomplis en la matière et puis vous
assurer que lorsque nous sommes rendus
notamment en Italie il y a une attente
qui est très forte de la part de ces
pays de première accueil la Grèce
également parlé de Chypre de l'Espagne
ou encore de Malte certes la France
paye le prix également des difficultés
en la matière mais je peux vous assurer
que lorsque vous voyez la situation dans
laquelle se trouve ces pays de première
accueil on voit bien la difficulté à ne
pas avoir aujourd'hui de conclusion sur
ces discussions entre état c'est aussi
la question vous le savez bien
du système de mode de fonctionnement de
notre union sur ces sujets ensuite vous
avez évoqué l'aide au développement
avec le questionnement
c'est une piste que nous avons voulu
privilégier parce que nous considérons
que une politique d'aide au
développement peut être de nature
parfois
en fonction de l'interlocuteur aussi moi
si j'ai pu me permettre l'expression
vous avez une politique d'aide au
développement qui doit être aussi
élaboré avec des partenaires sur avec
des démocraties établies et avec des
responsables gouvernementaux qui a sont
des partenaires sur et fiables
je pense aujourd'hui que si on n'est pas
sur une politique d'aide au
développement
si on facilite pas le développement de
de certains pays avec lesquels nous
avons cette
interaction en matière migratoire
je pense qu'on va on va marquer le pas
donc continuera à avoir des difficultés
et je considère que notre pays peut
avoir un rôle à jouer à la matière mais
il ne pourra également l'avoir que dans
le cas d'une action beaucoup plus
concertée au niveau de l'Union
européenne
encore une fois ce sont des pistes qui
sont pas au nom des deux courateurs nous
avons un travail
qui est un travail humblain on a fait un
constat on essaye de faire des
propositions qui vont dans le sens du
renforcement de
notre pays dans le cadre de ces
abigrations qui sont difficiles tout à
l'heure d'autres collègues à la fille à
parler d'humanité moi je l'ai évoqué dès
ma première réponse tout à l'heure
il y a aussi cette nécessaire humanité
que nous devons avoir par rapport à ces
problèmes et dans cette nécessaire
humanité il y a également de regarder
d'où viennent ces gens et d'essayer
aussi de cibler les problèmes qui
peuvent aujourd'hui les amener à quitter
leur pays hors cas de guerre ou de
persécution vous avez des problématiques
d'alimentation en eau en électricité de
développement de l'éducation et on le
sait très bien la France a aussi une
vocation à mon avis universelle en la
matière qu'elle doit jouer
alors je pense que c'est important pour
faire écho à ce qu'a dit le collègue
c'est important de comprendre que cette
logique
d'inertie au niveau du pacte européen en
fait elle fragilise beaucoup même l'idée
même européenne c'est à dire que c'est
un effet pervers ces pays du Sud se sont
abandonnés je suis moins diplomate que
mon voisin il se sentent abandonnés il y
a un ressentiment qui est profond
et en fait cette logique de dire la
géographie a raison de toute façon c'est
une frontière sud et c'est très bien et
en fait on va payer notre tranquillité
en versant des fonds on revient sur la
question de l'acceptabilité les
populations en fait elles ont peuvent
plus
et et cette inertie est perçue par
beaucoup comme de la lâcheté au niveau
de Bruxelles et moi je pense que ça a un
effet délétère sur même le projet
européen parce que ça le met en danger
parce que ça fait reculer l'adhésion à
ce projet européen même s'il y a des
fonds et nous on a vu sur place
évidemment beaucoup d'installations pour
les migrants sont financés par l'aide
européenne mais ça ne ça ne compense pas
ce que ce que ce que les populations
attendent et à mon avis de manière
légitime et la complexité de Dublin la
complexité de enfin c'est un on n'a pas
eu un interlocuteur qui a défendu Dublin
sonne lors de des auditions dans les a
multiplié le constat est unanime que ça
ne fonctionne pas sur la question de la
solidarité nationale vis-à-vis de
l'accueil de la migration à Mayotte
enfin les statistiques elles sont
claires les Comoriens une fois qu'ils
sont arrivés à Mayotte ne partent pas
quand ils sont régularisés qui peuvent
quitter l'île ils vont tous en métropole
leur objectif c'est l'Hexagone
merci il va falloir aller plus vite on
vous répondez vous avez vous avez vous
dites des choses très intéressantes mais
bon on peut pas avoir 5-6 minutes de
réponse à chacun sinon on ne s'en sort
pas le le suivant sur ma liste est
évidemment pour les socialistes à
parenté le célèbre à la David
merci monsieur le Président
Madame et Monsieur le Rapporteur chers
merci pour vos éclairages
j'ai noté que malgré l'augmentation
nette des flux nous restons encore loin
des chiffres connus en 2015
à l'époque l'Allemagne avait accueilli
l'essentiel de ces réfugiés certains
pays en Europe avaient refusé d'ailleurs
de jouer le jeu de la solidarité
au moment où comme vous le signalez le
Parlement pourrait examiner
énième texte franco-français sur le
sujet alors que la solution est
manifestement à trouver au niveau
européen je souhaiterais pour ma part
revenir sur l'un des chiffres que vous
mentionnez
celui du nombre estimé non pas du flux
d'entrée irrégulière en France mais du
stock de ces étrangers entre guillemets
dépourvu de titres de séjour
le ministre de l'Intérieur évoque entre
600 000 et 900 000 personnes sachant
qu'une petite moitié de ceci ferait
valoir leur droit à l'aide médicale
d'État alors que cette ame est
régulièrement attaquée je note coûte ça
vertu sanitaire en prévenant par exemple
le développement de certaines épidémies
cette amie de surcroît à le mérite de
permettre un décompte de ces étrangers
en situation irrégulière
à mon sens on ne peut enfin notre sens
on ne peut pas traiter ce problème sans
imaginer et initier une véritable
stratégie
humanitaire et humaine avec nos
partenaires européens
alors notre nous sommes très inquiets de
la situation à Mayotte
qui ne semble pas faire l'objet de
décision à la hauteur des difficultés et
des enjeux humains et humanitaires pour
ce territoire national
mais j'insiste sur le terme territoire
national
très bien merci monsieur le député
monsieur Marc Angel oui mon cher
collègue bon vous faites référence
effectivement au chiffre aux évaluations
du ministre de l'Intérieur dans le dans
le rapport et à une étude qui a été
réalisée sur la région parisienne et sur
le bassin bordelaise il mission de la
santé exacte qui qui font ressortir que
49% uniquement des des bénéficiaires
éventuels de l'Ame ils ont recours bon
c'est un débat qui est un débat d'ordre
national vous voyez bien que des
propositions ont été faites par
notamment nos collègues des républicains
en la matière
c'est un débat qui est ancien
j'ai souvenir de proposition de loi
examinée j'ai souvenir également que le
gouvernement en 2019 cette époque j'ai
sur ce qu'on appelle le panier de soins
[Musique]
puisque il y a quelques légendes
urbaines qui circulent tout de même sur
l'aide médicale d'État également aussi
des faits avérés parfois il y avait un
panel qui était trop large mais je
rappelle tout de même que le premier
soin c'est pour lutter contre la
tuberculose
et les épidémies donc je laisse quand
même réfléchir à toute la la partie
santé publique faut toujours avoir une
forme de recul et de réflexion si demain
nous avons sur notre sol des personnes
qui arrivent porteur de maladies et que
nous ne les soignons pas c'est notre
système tout entier qui peut en être
ensuite des stabiliser bon ensuite je je
l'aide médicale détail il y a un volet
spécifique concernant l'île de Mayotte
puisque ma collègue fait une proposition
claire en la matière vous avez bien vu
que le système je parle pour elle parce
que elle a très bien expliqué le système
hospitalier de Mayotte en train de
s'écrouler sur sur lui-même et si on
établit pas l'ame sur l'île de Mayotte
c'est le système de financement même de
la santé publique sur l'île de Mayotte
qui a risque d'être complètement
ravagé faut des choses comme elles le
sont donc c'est une réflexion que nous
mettons et si elle veut compléter je lui
laisse la parole si cher collègue
monsieur le Président je serais très
rapide moi sur la question la
coopération médicale parce que en fait
c'est sous-jacent dans votre question et
je vous en remercie moi je rappelle que
l'hôpital de Bambo es qui a été
construit par les fonds chinois qui est
flambant neuf qui a été construit au
Comores ne fonctionne pas
c'est à dire que il faut aussi
s'interroger sur parce que le collègue
en a parlé avec qui on travaille on peut
pas se substituer à l'État des
migrations s'il ne veut pas travailler
on ne peut pas le faire la place alors
place sans quoi on va dans l'ingérence
et c'est en fait c'est dramatique parce
que personne ne nie la situation de
détresse de celles et ceux qui viennent
se soigner en France je veux dire on est
on n'est pas des monstres mais en fait
la question de Mayotte elle pose la
question du partenaire
les Chinois ont investi des millions
d'euros pour construire un hôpital qui
ne fonctionne pas qui est laissé à
l'abandon qui étaient censés être un
plateau technique qui permettrait aux
comorien de se soigner chez eux il est
il y a des chèvres et toute la
végétation qui pousse dans le bloc
opératoire c'est dans les colonnes du
Monde assez récemment de 1 et de deux
comment dire la question de l'aide
médicale d'État c'est d'avoir un budget
qui soit dédié et qu'on puisse avoir la
clarté sur le coût de la santé des
étrangers il est pas question de ne pas
répondre au serment d'Hippocrate et de
soigner celles et ceux qui en ont besoin
il est il est question de d'avoir un
système de financement qui fonctionne et
que ce soit pas au détriment de la
patientèle nationale je vais je vais
être je rappelle le fonctionnement de la
santé à Mayotte et dérogatoire c'est une
enveloppe unique pour l'hôpital et donc
comme les oraux ne se multiplient pas
comme les petits pains de Jésus un euro
si vous mettez 50 centimes pour la santé
des étrangers c'est 50 centimes qui ne
vont pas pour la santé des Français de
Mayotte c'est aussi simple que ça le
refus de faire une tarification normale
avec l'ame c'est ça se traduit par une
difficulté d'accès à la santé c'est pour
ça que je me bats sur cette idée
c'est très clair pour horizon
qui va je pense être assez de l'appui de
ce rapport madame cochère
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Youssoupha monsieur Marc Angeli chez
Laurent merci pour ce rapport qui remet
en perspective de nombreux enjeux
migratoires au sud de l'Europe ou à
Mayotte il permet de prendre en compte à
la fois les enjeux propres à certaines
zones géographiques et événements
politiques récents mais aussi les causes
structurelles qui font que les
migrations sont susceptibles de durée la
crise climatique l'instabilité
économique mondiale et la situation
socio-économique dégradée de certains
pays d'Afrique du Nord constituent des
facteurs qui devraient durablement
affecter les flux migratoires vers
l'Europe
l'Europe se doit de trouver une réponse
coordonnée si nous voulons préserver la
qui communautaire de libre circulation
des personnes au sein de l'espace
Schengen c'est l'objet du règlement de
bublin comme vous l'avez dit dans votre
rapport qui doit permettre une
coordination entre État européen dans le
traitement des demandes d'asile or vous
le rappelez également ce règlement fait
peser un fardeau plus important sur les
pays de dernière de première entrée
pardon ce règlement doit être
réformé des pistes sont envisagées vous
les rappelez la Commission européenne a
ainsi proposé plusieurs règlements de
filtrage aux frontières extérieures ou
de procédures d'asile à la frontière
toutefois aucun de ces textes ne sont
pour leur définitivement adopter cela
fait courir le risque d'un aboutissement
des négociations tardif possiblement
au-delà des élections européennes de
alors madame le rapport madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur vous y
avez déjà répondu en partie quels sont
encore aujourd'hui les principaux points
de blocage chez les collègues
législateurs européens pour faire
aboutir le pacte européen sur la
migration et la je vous remercie
répondez aussi synthétiquement possible
je vous rends monsieur
je vais essayer d'être respectueux tout
même de
ma collègue il est né à mon ami
il y a l'essentiel des réponses dans la
page 61 notamment sur la règlement des
de Dublin de du rapport à savoir des
trois strates qu'on peut y voir vous
avez la première strate c'est des pays
premier accueil qui partagent entre pas
et des cinq pays formes de fardeau ils
sont très remontés
ils sont très remonter et on peut
comprendre qu'il le soit parce que ils
font face en première vague à quelque
chose d'assez difficile à gérer et ils
le font fait confiance à ma collègue à
la bien décrit notamment à
ils le font dans des conditions qui
devraient ne pas être caricaturé
et aspirer parfois
il y a des états de second rideau
l'Allemagne et la France en font partie
ils demandent ils te font ils font la
demande au pays de première arrivée
d'être sérieux dans l'enregistrement etc
donc ça bloque un petit peu puis après
vous les avez les autres pays qui
veulent entendre parler de rien du tout
par exemple de la Hongrie
ils ne veulent pas du tout partager
l'effort sur l'accueil et d'abord bon il
y a quand même cette cette phrase de
Didier Deski il y a une dizaine de pays
où se concentre la demande d'asile par
rapport à la somme de l'UE pour des
raisons culturelles et historiques des
pays de l'Est de l'Europe voient peu de
personnes venant du sud du monde ça
c'est vrai mais pour qu'on puisse en
dire aujourd'hui
ça a chope notamment sur Dublin personne
n'est content parce que vous avez en
réalité des des divergences sur l'état
des faits actuels donc c'est assez
compliqué c'est très compliqué
merci Monsieur Sollier nous passons donc
à Madame sebbayi pour la le groupe
écologiste à parenté
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues merci aux deux rapporteurs de
permettre d'avoir ce temps d'échange
moi je voudrais commencer par dire en
fait parce que j'ai une vraie question
c'est combien de morts il va falloir
attendre avant en fait qu'on réfléchisse
a complètement changé notre politique
migratoire et de réfléchir non pas à
comment barricader et fermer nos
frontières mais plutôt comment
travailler à accueillir dignement les
gens qui migrent aujourd'hui non pas par
envie ou parce qu'ils ont décidé un beau
matin en se réveillant qu'il fallait
qu'il quittent leur territoire et parce
qu'il y a des causes réelles qui font
qu'il migrent aujourd'hui que ce soit
les guerres ça a été dit les famines
bien d'autres choses ou encore dans un
temps qui va arriver bien trop vite
malheureusement la question du
changement climatique puisqu'on estime
que d'ici 2050 ça sera 216 millions de
personnes qui seront sur les routes
migratoires et qu'il faudra accueillir
on va pas barricader mettre des miradors
partout autour de l'Europe
pour éviter qu'il rentre ou un mec ça ne
fonctionne pas parce que déjà il rentre
quand même mais qu'en plus ça se fait
avec perte et fracas puisque beaucoup
d'entre eux beaucoup trop périssent
aujourd'hui sur la route est mort
notamment en mer et je pense que parfois
on a tendance à oublier qu'on vit dans
un territoire et dans un continent qui
est à peu près préservé aujourd'hui par
la question du changement climatique et
qu'on a la chance finalement de vivre
dans un pays comme la France ou en
Europe qui nous permet de pouvoir
continuer à y vivre sans avoir à subir
ce que subissent certains États
notamment les sécheresses ou encore les
inondations telles que l'on connaissent
certains pays ça a été dit je pense que
aujourd'hui ça ne fonctionne pas parce
que effectivement l'effort ne repose pas
à l'échelle de l'Europe et que ça ne
peut pas reposer que sur certains états
si on veut que ça fonctionne il faut que
la solidarité se fasse à l'échelle de
l'Europe bien évidemment et là je pense
que la suppression de la procédure du
blanc est une priorité c'est une
nécessité si on veut que les choses
fonctionnent et qu'on puisse accueillir
dignement dans notre pays enfin à
l'échelle de l'Europe en tout cas je
suis assez d'accord avec ce qu'a dit mon
collègue socialiste je pense que
aujourd'hui la question laboratoire elle
ne se réfléchit pas à l'échelle juste de
la France mais bien à l'échelle
européenne si on veut en tout cas
pouvoir avoir des résultats et j'avoue
que moi c'est plutôt ça qui me
questionne c'est pour ça que j'ai envie
de vous entendre c'est plutôt au lieu de
voir ça comme un fardeau mais en réalité
il faut se dire que de toute manière
nous n'aurons pas le choix et qu'il faut
pouvoir travailler à créer les
conditions donc quelle politique
migratoire non pas dans le sens comment
fermer mais plutôt quelle politique
migratoire digne pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que les choses s'améliorent pour
nous mais aussi pour ceux qu'on devra
accueillir dans les années qui viennent
je vous remercie je vous remercie madame
la député madame et monsieur le
rapporteur les rapporteur merci chers
collègues alors au risque de de vous
corriger Mayotte subit le changement
climatique
et très gravement nous on a pas d'eau
dans notre robinet 4 jours par semaine
parce que les routes cycloniques les
routes de pluviométrie ont changé et une
partie de la migration à Mayotte était
aussi provoquée par le changement
climatique que la région subie et je ne
peux pas ici ne pas mentionner l'alerte
qui a été lancé par l'ONU qui annonce le
phénomène El ninio pour les deux
prochaines années
qui a un phénomène climatique de
sécheresse et de plus diluvienne qui va
continuer à complètement déstabiliser
sur les deux prochaines années ça veut
dire pour nous plus de migrants donc la
question n'est pas de dire c'est est-ce
que c'est ou pas une vision de dire que
c'est un fardeau je pense que le rapport
est très clair sur le fait que c'est
effectivement un fardeau pour Mayotte
moi je peux pas en toute amitié vous
vous entendez me dire que que c'est que
c'est une vision une perception c'est
une réalité factuelle et en fait notre
propos est de nous inviter nous tous
collectivement ici dans la
représentation nationale de prendre
appui sur ces situations de crise aiguë
parce que vous avez absolument raison
les flux migratoires sur les prochaines
décennies vont s'intensifier donc soit
on continue à se dire c'est des
problèmes
géographiquesmentalisés ça suffit bien
et puis jusqu'à ce que ça implose on va
laisser mariner le sujet soit on s'en
empare on tire les leçons de ces cas qui
sont des concentrations de nos
incohérences de nos impensés de nos
hypocrisies de nos limites parce que
c'est c'est un concentré c'est un
concentré de drame humain de grande
lâcheté
et aussi de faiblesses structurelles
c'est-à-dire que ces situations de crise
qu'on a pu observer que ce soit à
Mayotte en Grèce ou en Italie c'est des
situations qui sont en fait par leur
charge le résumé elles mettent sous
tension tout le système et c'est aussi
des chocs sociaux moi je pense que c'est
très important je peux pas ne pas
mentionner la dimension humaine qui est
très importante les drames dont vous
parlez
on en est témoin
quotidiennement c'est pas une
abstraction et c'est traumatisant pour
les sociétés d'accueil voir se déverser
une misère humaine aussi importante
quotidiennement c'est un choc
moi je vais me permettre de le raconter
il y a un Grec qui nous a raconté que
lui il a ramassé
un papa qui portait cinq enfants cinq
enfants et qui qui était en train de
mourir déshydraté et de faim avec ses
gamins il a dit je n'arrive plus à aller
sur cette même route parce que j'ai
cette image qui est imprimée dans le
crâne donc je pense que à un moment
c'est pas une question de dire qu'on est
dans le déni et je ne pense pas que de
romantiser ou de dire que c'est c'est on
va abolir les frontières les frontières
elles existent il faut les respecter je
vous remercie
monsieur le Président vous avez rien à
ajouter c'était très convaincant ce que
dit Madame Youssoupha ce qui ne veut pas
dire que ce qu'a dit Madame cela il
n'était pas pour la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine c'est le vice-président le
coq
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues le rapport présent à part sur
les enjeux migratoires aux frontières
sud de l'Union européenne et de l'océan
Indien n'est pas satisfaisant pour notre
groupe nous votre compte sa publication
du fait d'une vision répressive du
traitement des migrations premièrement
j'aurais voulu savoir pourquoi vous
n'avez pas approfondi le problème du
visa manager en poser en 1995 entre
trois îles et Comores et Mayotte
dans votre rapport les conditions
d'octroi de ce visa pour certains
Comoriens sont quasiment hors de portée
aboutissants presque systématiquement un
refus d'octroi cela oblige les Comoriens
des trois autres îles que Mayotte qui
souhaiteraient venir sur le lit de
Mayotte à entrer dans l'illégalité et
prendre des risques mortels on doit
rappeler ici ce matin qu'on compte en 30
ans plus de 10000 morts dans le bras de
mer qui sépare l'île de Mayotte de celle
d'en juin vous avez nommé une partie je
cite des flux au service d'une
revendication de souveraineté d'un État
étranger reste que la question de la
souveraineté de cet État étranger est
posé du fait du processus qui a été mis
en oeuvre pour la départementalisation
de Mayotte et vous avez la mémoire que
notre groupe c'était prononcé contre ce
processus de départementalisation et
c'est ce qui pose problème d'ailleurs
encore à l'ONU même si le droit d'un
peuple à disposer de lui-même existe il
n'empêche que quand il y a une
revendication territoriale
ne pas évoquer ces graves dérives nuit
gravement à l'exhaustivité à laquelle
devrait prétendre un rapport
d'information de la commission des
affaires étrangères et puis madame leur
rapporteur vous avez interpellé sur la
comment l'Union européenne pourrait agir
à Mayotte elle ne peut pas le faire je
le pense alors que le droit
international considère Mayotte comme
comorienne encore aujourd'hui et je
pense que si elle le faisait elle serait
très vite attaquée par la Cour
européenne de justice en tout cas remise
en côte comme c'est le cas par exemple
au Sahara occidental ou dans d'autres
endroits je pense que c'est pour cela
qu'elle ne peut pas se saisir la
question merci Monsieur le
vice-président je crois qu'il y a
beaucoup de questions qui sont posées
essayez de répondre très factuellement
très précisément mais très rapidement
parce que nous sommes vraiment hors
délais
je vous remercie alors je je ne vais pas
re-rentrer dans le débat sur Mayotte et
les revendications des commandes donc
vous faites le relai ici
étant élu à l'Assemblée nationale et
discutant des lois françaises et des
lois européennes je ne vais pas ici
donner libre cours
ou revendications des Comores à l'ONU
sachant que le droit français prime il
sauf erreur Mayotte est inscrit à la
Constitution à la constitution c'est un
territoire français et je ne vais pas
ici débattre des revendications d'un
pays étranger par ailleurs sur la
question des morts en mer qui sont le
chiffre que vous que vous indiquez n'est
pas vérifié je vais comment dire
respecter les instructions du président
et ne pas répondre plus avant mais moi
je vous rappelle que nous maori avons
choisi de rester français nous sommes
français nous n'allons pas ici subir ce
discours qui remet en cause notre
attachement à la France pour entendre
les revendications d'un pays qui est en
train de déstabiliser et de détruire
Mayotte par ailleurs la question du visa
Balladur c'est quand même la base s'il y
a une frontière il y a un visa sauf s'il
y a libre circulation ou que les Comores
sont partis de l'Union européenne ce qui
n'est pas le cas donc la question de la
remise en cause du visa Balladur c'est
toujours la même chose remettre en cause
maillot de français donc c'est non
Youssoupha a tout dit sur Mayotte
madame oui très bien
la question maintenant au titre des
inscrits madame Ménard
merci monsieur le Président et merci à
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs pour
ce rapport qui est passionnant et qui
fourmi l'information extrêmement
intéressante ma question va porter plus
sur les minorisées ou les mineurs non
accompagnés ils sont estimés à plus de
40 000 sur le territoire national et si
tous évidemment est fort heureusement ne
sont pas des délinquants il y en a
environ 10% qui se sont fait
particulièrement remarquer pour leur
violence débridée des lits et crimes qui
sont malheureusement de tristes tableau
de chasse de certains d'entre eux le
rapport que vous nous avez présenté
continue de nous interpeller puisqu'il
confirme la montée en puissance continue
du flux de mineur non accompagné en
France les chiffres de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance parlent d'eux-mêmes en 2015 on
comptait 5990 MNA qui étaient pris en
charge en 2022 14 782 donc une
multiplication par 3 qui a évidemment un
coup puisqu'en moyenne on considère
qu'un mineur non accompagné qui est pris
en charge coûte au contribuable français
à peu près 500 euros par an tout frais
confondu donc si vous faites le calcul
en 2022 plus de 730 millions d'euros
il y a des solutions qui existent pour
pour lutter contre cette afflux massif
même si c'est très compliqué je le
conseille mais la situation est
extrêmement compliquée de toute façon
c'est solutions ont été présentées à
plusieurs reprises au gouvernement lors
du précédent mandat je pense notamment à
la possibilité des tests osseux pour
détecter les vrais faux mineurs sur des
décisions judiciaires bien évidemment
elle expulsion de MNA après comparution
immédiate en cas de commission d'un
délit ou d'un écrivez
j'en passe certaines autres qui ont été
effectivement développées à plusieurs
reprises dans l'hémicycle mais
malheureusement les chiffres aujourd'hui
parlent d'eux-mêmes la situation est
évidemment hors de contrôle pour
l'instant et j'ai donc plusieurs
questions à poser d'abord à Madame
Youssoupha est-ce que vous savez à
combien on estime le nombre de mineurs
non accompagnés à Mayotte
et puis Mayotte semble avoir à gérer
localement les mineurs dans la compagnie
qui arrivent sur ces plages quels moyens
devrait être déployé selon vous pour
soutenir les maorets dans cette bataille
contre les migrations illégales alors
vous en avez déjà fait un petit peu état
mais j'aimerais bien avoir un petit peu
plus de précision et enfin comment sont
accompagnés les mineurs dans la
compagnie dès lors qu'ils sont dans
l'incapacité par définition de présenter
des papiers et les papiers nécessaires à
leur entrée légale sur notre territoire
comment ça se passe concrètement à mes
yacht vu la situation catastrophique que
nous vous nous avez décrite je vous
remercie
merci Madame Ménard merci monsieur le
Président donc en fait les chiffres les
plus bas à Mayotte font état d'environ
6000 mineurs isolés on est en réalité
environ 10 000 mineurs isolés étrangers
les services du conseil départemental
puisque je rappelle que les dépenses
pour la prise en charge des mineurs
étrangers isolés c'est le conseil
départemental des conseils
départementaux c'est une responsabilité
que l'État a transféré au niveau local
cette prise en charge elle coûte enfin
le conseil départemental de Mayotte
n'arrive plus à payer la facture et donc
aujourd'hui les familles d'accueil
mahoraises accueillent trois fois plus
d'enfants c'est à dire une dizaine en
moyenne que le seuil légal autorisé
la pour celles et ceux qui basculent
dans la violence le placement décidé par
la justice se fait à l'insu des familles
d'accueil
qui subissent la présence de jeunes
dangereux sans en être informé et sans
avoir été formé pour les accueillir
c'est à dire que ça pose un risque pour
les familles d'accueil les enfants qui
sont eux aussi accueillis
et moi je veux dire ici que ces mineurs
isolés sont une enfance en danger
un mineur isolé avant tout c'est un
mineur qui est en danger il représente
maintenant un danger pour le reste de la
population parce qu'ils sont en défiance
vis-à-vis des adultes mais ils sont
souvent la proie de travail sexuel de
travail forcé de mise en danger et en
fait la l'incapacité des adultes à
mettre en place des réponses adéquates
augmente leur vulnérabilité et donc leur
radicalité dans la réponse est des
jeunes enfants ou des jeunes adultes
donc ils ont des réponses qui sont
ultra-violes et c'est aussi ce qui
explique la violence qu'on subit à
Mayotte le phénomène des enfants isolés
ça fait plusieurs années que les
autorités locales de dénoncent et en
fait un jeune il reste pas jeune toute
sa vie il grandit donc ça devient des
jeunes adultes ultra violents qui ne
sont pas capables de socialisation qui
sont pas capables de rapport à
l'autorité qui sont en révolte absolue
et donc ultra violentes donc oui pour
moi cette question
elle se pose parce qu'on l'a vu sa
défrayé la chronique ici à Paris en
Île-de-France de savoir que ces jeunes
étaient
ultra violents et je pense que ça nous
interroge nous adultes ça nous interroge
nous parce que à Mayotte il faut
comprendre que les adultes nous sommes
minoritaires par rapport au mineur
faut bien comprendre cette situation
parce qu'elle est incroyablement hors du
commun les structures en fait tout ce
qu'on réfléchit pour l'accueil il y a
pas la capacité
c'est effectivement très intéressant
monsieur
je crois que je te l'ai tout dit oui oui
vous avez la question sur la course
on apporte pas sa bière à Munich
n'est-ce pas
bon maintenant je me suis Joris Evrard
on passe aux questions particulières
donc une minute et
madame et monsieur le rapporteur une
minute dans vos réponses au plus chacun
monsieur Evrard merci monsieur le
Président Madame Monsieur le Rapporteur
donc la troisième partie de votre
rapport concerne les enjeux migratoires
dans le traitement n'est pas à la
hauteur et appelle de nouvelles réponses
le rassemblement national ne peut être
que d'accord tant le titre qu'avec son
développement donc au point 2 sur les
migrations instrumentalisées page 57 et
58 vous mentionnez que l'Union des
Comores voit les flux migratoires comme
une arme au service de sa revendication
de notre territoire vous rappeler que
lors de la présidente française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne
l'instrumentalisation des migrants et
des migrations est une attaque hybride
donc l'OTAN on va même plus loin en
pointant le fait que c'est phénomènes
sont amenés après en plus d'ampleur
madame monsieur le rapporteur vous
préconisez d'intégrer dans la politique
française la dimension politique aux
stratégique des migrations pourriez-vous
nous indiquer pourquoi cette naïveté
dont vous faites état fait l'objet d'un
constat aussi clair lorsqu'il s'agit de
nos territoires de l'océan Indien et de
critiques aussi importantes lorsqu'il
s'agit de notre territoire hexagonal je
vous remercie merci pour vos réponses je
vous remercie monsieur marchangel je
crois avoir répondu tout à l'heure à
votre collègue sur la question moi je
n'ai aucune naïveté aucun angélisme sur
la question je crois également dans le
cadre de l'accueil sur le territoire
métropolitain les pressions qui sont
suivies par le pays doivent être prises
en compte dans le cadre de nos relations
internationales et dans notre politique
de défense bon monsieur marcongele
répond qu'il n'est pas naïf et Madame
Youssoupha a montré tout au long de ses
réponses qu'elle ne n'était pas non plus
je pose donc donne donc la parole à
Madame Laetitia Saint-Paul
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur
merci à Mayotte d'avoir choisi la France
aujourd'hui les trois autres
îles comoriennes ont choisi
l'indépendance et effectivement alors
que Mayotte était un pôle de stabililité
souffre de l'instabilité de de choix
politiques conduit par ces dirigeants et
je pense qu'il faut pas exclusivement ce
placer sur le champ moral lorsque j'ai
conduit une délégation de la commission
des affaires étrangères aux Comores les
Comoriens m'ont dit souffrir de la
pression migratoire de du sud du
continent africain donc je voulais
savoir si c'est également ce que vous
aviez constaté ici tel est le cas
avons-nous besoin d'une énième loi
immigration ou est-ce que c'est pas
plutôt une loi contre les trafiquants
parce que et là je soutiens tout à fait
l'aspect sécuritaire
le terrorisme alimenté surtout par trois
trafics le trafic de drogue la traite
d'êtres humains parce que c'est ce dont
il est question c'est même plus question
d'immigration et le trafic d'espèces
menacées une minute 5 monsieur le
Président je vous remercie alors pour
merci Madame Saint-Paul alors pour
répondre en fait je pense que il faut
rappeler 96% de l'immigration à Mayotte
c'est une immigration comorienne par
contre avec beaucoup d'intelligence
Moroni met en avant et facilite la
migration qui arrive des Grands Lacs je
dis avec beaucoup d'intelligence parce
que la sensibilité qui peut y avoir à
Paris sur la migration africaine rend ce
levier très intéressant pour Moroni qui
a introduit dans son discours sur la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
de dire qu'il sert désormais de remparts
à l'immigration africaine à Mayotte ce
qui est quand même risible quand on sait
que ce sont les autorités comoriennes
qui encouragent et facilitent et accueil
l'immigration africaine il y a village
qui sont organisés aux Comores pour
accueillir l'immigration africaine et
qui organise leur transfert vers Mayotte
donc je pense qu'il faut pas être dupe
de l'instrumentalisation que font les
autorités comoriennes de cette migration
africaine Moroni a aller vidange tiré
les leçons de la rente
qu'a obtenu le président
Erdogan sur la le chantage migratoire
vis-à-vis de l'Union européenne c'est
très clair c'est ce qu'a expliqué le
collègue Marc Angeli ce qu'on obtenu les
présidents Kadhafi
Erdogan et qu'on sort en faisant marcher
la peur en Europe vis-à-vis de l'arrivée
des migrants africains bah c'est aussi
arrivé aux oreilles de Moroni et c'est
ce qu'on observe je vous remercie
maintenant il reste monsieur Alexis Joly
puis après Monsieur Le Gall merci
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur
l'enclave de Ceuta territoire espagnol
en Afrique du Nord et l'une des portes
d'entrée de l'immigration clandestine
sur le territoire européen et fait
office de pierre d'achoppement entre
l'Espagne et le Maroc depuis plusieurs
années la fumigatoire de ce territoire
permet au Maroc de faire pression sur
les frontières européennes avec un pic
en mai 2021 ou plus de 8000 migrants ont
pu passer en quelques jours alors
l'actualité politique espagnole et la
victoire probable du bloc de droite aux
prochaines élections législatives
convoquées en juillet risque d'accroître
les tensions entre le Royaume chérifien
et l'Europe avec la à l'arrivée à la
montcloade un nouveau Premier ministre
plus hostile à l'immigration que
l'actuel Premier ministre Pedro Sanchez
alors dans ce cadre qu'elle soit à vos
yeux les perspectives d'évolution
concernant la situation migratoire dans
l'enclave de Ceuta et quelles
conséquence peuvent-elles avoir sur les
relations diplomatiques entre notre
continent et le Maroc je vous remercie
on vous demandez à nos rapporteurs
d'être dans la boule de cristal des
futurs électeurs européens
un travail d'anticipation audacieux vous
leur demandez monsieur Marc Angel alors
monsieur le Président merci mon cher
collègue vous avez compris qu'on a
peut-être est-ce une erreur
parti pris a été peut-être de moins de
traiter cette porte d'entrée là dans le
cadre des travaux que nous avons mené
puisque nous ne sommes pas rendus en
Espagne nous avons privilégié en Europe
la Grèce et l'Italie mais effectivement
la question que vous posez mérite d'être
mise sur la table parce que quand je
vous parle des relations bilatérales que
la France peut avoir avec des pays
dides de migration ça peut aussi
concerner ce pays auquel vous faisiez
référence et naturellement nos voisins
et amis espagnols vont être confrontés
ça ne donne pas d'hier il y a des
revendications territoriales également
qui ne doivent pas d'hier avec des
situations de guerre entre l'Espagne et
le Maroc
ça fait partie des enjeux
qui a devant être pris en compte et qui
seront certainement liés au débat
électoral que nos voisins et amis
espagnols vont avoir puisque cela joue
fortement sur l'entrée sur le territoire
je rappelle quand même encore une fois
il y a 5 pays qui sont des porte
d'entrée l'Espagne en fait partie elle
suit beaucoup de pression même si le
parti pris du rapport porté davantage
sur l'Italie et la Grèce le niveau
européen et naturellement Mayotte
puisque ce qui se passe là-bas et tout
de même assez dramatique
je vous remercie je vous remercie
Monsieur Le Gall
une minute monsieur legal alors je
voudrais d'abord commencer par dire que
c'est il paye personne ne baguette
magique que moi j'ai entendu et je suis
parfaitement sensible au constat qui est
fait sur la situation je voudrais juste
revenir sur la dimension onusienne
parce que l'ONU c'est aussi le un
vecteur de puissance pour la France et
on y fait des compromis parfois on y
gagne parfois en hyper
sur les zones économiques spéciales par
exemple exclusives pardon la France a
beaucoup gagné au droit international
sur d'autres secteurs elle perd donc je
peux pas vous laisser madame oussois
parce que c'est faux dire que le droit
international ne l'emporte pas et c'est
un vecteur de puissance pour la France
et le droit international à l'archid
énorme est supérieure au droit national
ça ne veut pas dire que il faut pas
régler le problème mais voilà donc moi
j'ai pas de baguette magique et je
donnerais de leçons à personne mais ils
savaient explique aussi qu'il faudrait
tirer les leçons du fait qu'on a laissé
pourrir des situations pendant des
décennies y compris et ça a été voté
dans les années 70 ici on a tordu la
question du vote sur l'indépendance et
on en paye le prix ici moi je suis ni
pour ni contre je pense c'est au peuple
de décider mais on a dès le départ
créer une situation qui portait les
germes de difficultés immenses donc
maintenant faut les résoudre question
mais n'oublions pas une chose l'ONU
c'est pas une faiblesse pour la France
c'est un vecteur de puissance et c'est
pour ça que vous le dites un état que
vous dites Lilliputiens arrive à nous
faire
une question à obtenir beaucoup madame
madame je vous invite à ne pas rentrer
dans un grand débat et répondre
précisément à marquer votre différence
si tenter qu'elle apparaisse qui me
paraît logique par rapport à ce qu'elle
dit Monsieur Le Gall je vous remercie
monsieur le Président je pense qu'il est
quand même nécessaire de rappeler que la
condamnation a eu la condamnation de la
France par rapport à Mayotte a eu lieu à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
qu'elle n'a pas vocation que ce n'est
pas au Conseil de sécurité que ça n'a
donc pas de vocation à s'imposer par
rapport à notre droit donc je ne vais
pas ici pour quelqu'un qui dit on peut
perdre ou gagner vous parlez d'un
territoire habité et que vous dites
respecter la volonté des peuples on
s'est exprimé moi je ne comprends pas
qu'en 2023 on me repose la question de
la décolonisation elle a eu lieu les
Comores sont indépendantes Mayotte et
rester française merci
c'est clairement voilà c'est des propos
des propos très très clairs monsieur
Marcon gilesque d'une façon au delà les
questions toutes les interlocuteurs se
sont exprimés est-ce que vous voulez
dire un mot de Madame madame Soufa dit
vraiment je crois tout ce qu'elle ce
qu'elle estimait de voir dire sur
Mayotte est-ce que vous avez un mot
ajouté sur l'ensemble du rapport ou
est-ce que vous trouvez ce que je pense
assez volontiers que la Commission a été
très complètement informée par vos soins
parce que vous avez raison
viens
donc la discussion générale est close
alors on va mettre au revoir la
publication du rapport j'ai cru
comprendre que il y avait certains
groupes qui n'étaient pas favorables
donc il faut il faut il faut il faut
passer au vote donc conformément à
l'article 145 du Règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale il revient à
présent à notre commission se prononcer
sur la publication du rapport
d'information que viennent de nous
présenter nos deux rapporteurs je
rappelle à tous fin utile que votre
notre vote ne porte pas je le dis pour
sur le contenu du rapport mais sur sa
diffusion comme document officiel de
engageons les rapporteurs et l'engageons
pas donc l'ensemble de la commission je
consulte la commission qui est pour la
publication
vous avez compté qui est contre
qui s'abstient
voilà il me semble qu'une très large
majorité c'est dégagé en la faveur de en
faveur de la publication ce dont je
félicite nos deux rapporteurs c'était un
échange extrêmement intéressant on peut
discuter les les
conclusions du rapport bien entendu
c'est notre rôle que discuter mais je
crois que c'était très enrichissant que
cette contribution qui a été
magnifiquement présenté défendu par
Monsieur Marc Angeli et par Madame
Youssoupha qui ont je crois
nous ont donné un espèce de duo d'opéra
absolument parfait c'était c'était tout
à fait tout à fait
remarquable à l'Athéna le ténor et la
soprano c'était très bien
la séance la séance est levée